[Music]
any country that devalues their currency
in order to take advantage of the United
States and its workers will be met very
very sharply and that includes tariffs
and taxes for their goods coming into
the country will be imposing tariffs on
steel imports in tariffs on aluminum
imports and give them to see a lot of
good things happen you're going to see
expansions of the companies it'll be 25%
for steel it'll be 10% for aluminum
president announcing tariffs not making
an official until next week the markets
got spooked by all of that today a lot
of people were surprised it came out
today when it comes to steel imports the
United States is the world's largest
steel importer twenty six point nine
million metric tons of steel imported
into the US and 2017 here's the
interesting thing if you thought this
was all about China the top ten sources
of steel imports into the u.s. they're
not China number one is Canada Brazil
South Korea actually ten of the top 12
are allies of the US you look at
aluminum china is number three if this
was all about China but Canada at 43% is
the number one exporter into the u.s. of
aluminum so what about all of this and
where this heads let's bring in our
panel Mike Allen co-founder of Axios
Katie Pavlich news editor at
townhall.com
and Mo Alethea executive director of the
Georgetown Institute of Politics okay
Mike there's a big battle on on this
issue the president campaigned on it it
shouldn't be a surprise but yet
unrolling it out like this was it was a
surprising it was not just a surprise to
the markets it was a shock inside and I
can't overstate how unusual it is for
White House aides a couple of hours
before big presidential event have no
idea and this tells you how they think
compared to how the presidents think
they were telling us he can't
do this the paperwork isn't done and the
president has been saying he wants to do
this Axios is reported in some EDC safe
bring me my tariffs so this is the
president getting what he wanted and the
chart that you showed there is part of
the argument that aides have been making
to delay try to put this off by sometime
yeah Gary Cohen is one of those pushing
back but obviously it has a supporter in
Wilbur Ross at commerce in light Heiser
the Trade Representative and as I
mentioned he campaigned on this in some
of the states that are really affected
by some of these now yeah the
administration is gambling on the idea
that the ends will justify the means
here they know that it's a big risk
history shows that tariffs aren't always
good for the United States and they
certainly aren't good when it comes to
putting these taxes on our our allies
this might be about China we do need to
find ways to punish them they steal our
intellectual property they constantly
cheat on the economy there have been a
number of people who push back on the
way that the president is going about
this but I think we have to give it time
this is a president who has blown things
up before people have panicked issued
their statements of condemnation saying
it will never work and in a lot of cases
it has so this is a big risk for the
administration to take but I think that
we'll just have to wait and see how well
it plays out yeah here is light hyzer
and Senator sass earlier on this show
the response that we're going to start a
trade war is nonsense we have a very
very imbalanced relationship with China
the president is beyond engaged he cares
about jobs and wages politics never
comes up and when he's not thinking
about jobs and wages it's wages and jobs
trade is great for America trade is
great for American families and no trade
war has ever worked we don't want to
make America in 1930 again and the
Forgotten men and women of America don't
want to be drafted into a trade war if
you own a steel mill today was great for
you if you consume steel and every
American family at the store tonight
bought something that has different
metals in it today is a bad day for you
mow this is two for two for Democrats
and when it comes to gun control and on
this issue sherrod Brown putting out a
statement supporting this kind of thing
how does it stand look
know that you would find unanimity and
the Democratic Party on this or I think
there are a lot of Democrats out there
who support free trade and who were very
nervous about a trade war right I mean
yeah I thought senators at this point
there was interesting if you are a steel
manufacturer you're happy tonight if you
are a steel consumer right like hold on
to your horses because things are about
to get really rocky the last time we had
one of these in 2002 and president
george w bush imposed tariffs on on
steel we saw not just threats of
retaliation
for me from the EU on the american
agricultural sector right so American
farmers ought to be sweating it right
now but you also saw manufacturing
plants that are consumers of Steel put
out reports talking about how they had
to layoff 200,000 American workers and
jack up their prices so there's going to
be a lot of political I think alliances
beforehand against terrorists back in
the Bush administration and they lasted
21 months and they eventually were
pulled down for that very reason because
there were threats for retaliation
does this go through does this see a lot
of resistance on Capitol Hill well but
the important thing to watch and your 12
countries there tells the story like
over the next week there's gonna be a
ferocious battle in the West Wing over
your shoulder and elsewhere in this town
for what are gonna be the carve-outs
because the paperwork was not done the
president did this this was if you're
against it you considered a crime of
opportunity the President had a couple
aides who were for it and they pushed
this through but now they'll try to
sweat out do we take out Canada do we
take out Europe like that's gonna make a
huge difference you can almost hear the
phone's ringing on K Street yeah all
right I want to talk about guns and
we've got a little montage of some of
the sound coming out of the past day and
a half the president said a lot of
things right yes
of course in similar meetings we've been
disappointed in the past I don't care
I'll take all the heat you want to give
me and I'll take the heat off both the
Democrats and the Republicans that
cannot happen on guns I know if the
comprehensive bill came to the floor on
background checks it would win there are
things that we can do that have
widespread bipartisan support that we
can act on that we can get past the week
will go by another week another week
another week and all of a sudden people
are gonna be on to other things we can't
let that happen
okay the president's gotten a lot of
praise for these open cabinet meetings
where he kind of talks about all kinds
of things but the one on guns yesterday
really raised some eyebrows especially
from the NRA and gun supporters yeah I
mean I don't know where to start with
what happened yesterday I mean for the
president to sit there and essentially
punch the NRA in the nose multiple times
by essentially downplaying their
importance saying directly he doesn't
necessarily need them and then for him
to have Dianne Feinstein Senator Dianne
Feinstein openly resubmit her right did
she was jumping for joy quite literally
out of her seat resubmit her her ban on
a number of semi-automatic rifles which
the Clinton Justice Department said did
nothing to combat crime numbers when it
came to criminals who are using firearms
in crimes did nothing to actually reduce
the number of mass shootings in this
country I talked to a number of NRA
members today who were saying look we've
we are willing to give the president a
pass on a number of things but the
Second Amendment and caving to the
emotions of this the do something
attitude when this was a failure at the
local level and at the federal level in
terms of law enforcement it's a red line
for us we're not gonna go there I'm a
little cynical on the political thing
and that the positioning of Dianne
Feinstein there could be trouble for her
in the primary in California how close
are you to Donald Trump I don't know I
mean you know if there's all kinds of
plays I don't know if this plays into
into primary politics I'm old enough I'm
old enough to remember when one of the
number-one talking points against Barack
Obama and Hillary Clinton and Bill
Clinton was the Democrats are gonna come
and illegally seized your guns
yesterday the president United States
sat there and said seize the guns first
due process later
a Republican president has gone further
to talk about seized illegally seizing
firearms than any Democratic president
ever had which is what senator sass
talked about earlier Mike 10 seconds
does something get done something does
get done but very minimalist the
calculation up here is that whatever
credit Republicans would get for going
further on guns than they have in the
past they would paid more of a price
with their own people so it's gonna be a
couple of things nothing like what the
president was talking about and they
really told him that around the table
they said not this time as 12 seconds